[Music]
hello i'm justin long and welcome hello
oh life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to a special quarantine
episode of life is short life could be a
dream sweetheart
with me as always is my sassy ver this
quarantine has made you very sassy
sassier
um i i
christian yeah long yeah sorry i'm sorry
uh i'd be weird this is the first
episode you listen to if you're just if
you're just tuning in if you only listen
to quarantine episodes
finally they did a quarantine episode
i've been waiting for the
whole time's been out
when are they doing a pandemic pandemic
um
we are uh like many of you quarantined
socially distancing we've been doing it
now for
what day is this 14 um
maybe not i have not had human contact
since
um
saturday before last so it's been you
mean not had human we've been you've
been with your girlfriend
i mean i don't count i was a human now
we should say to people it's been 15
days since i've had human contact it's
been yeah it's been two weeks since i
saw anyone
um christian just had a little cough you
may have heard and
uh we should tell everyone
that uh you actually might have corona
you think you do i i
do have it i think i might have it i
think justin has it as well and we're
not just being paranoid no and and by
the way way to bury the lead on our
parts we should start off saying this
but um uh sadly christian's girlfriend
maggie came back from her work trip and
a couple days later she was very ill um
it had classic uh corona symptoms she
had a fever
and dry cough all the things uh that
they're saying people have with uh covet
and
uh she's on day 12 of it now and
thankfully in the last
uh 24 hours or so she's had no fever and
seems to be doing a lot better so
that's good but the weird thing is
um the day after she came down with
symptoms a couple weeks ago
justin and i both
came down with
very mild versions of the exact same
symptoms yeah it was this achiness
some nausea headaches
and then the tightness in the chest we
started noticing so it was but then the
strangest thing that happened uh which
we then read was typical of of this uh
disease is that it hasn't happened to me
but um maggie and christian
uh lost their sense of taste and smell
it's very strange
yeah and knowing how much you love food
that must be the one that well also it's
i've never experienced that obviously
when you have a cold and you're you're
uh yeah but you're not congested
yeah so it's it's so weird to not be
congested and still have no sense of
smell or taste it's very strange but
that was um that was the thing that
convinced me that i had it i was quite
sure i had it but now i'm convinced um
and but unfortunately we can't get the
tests because
we're not considered high enough yeah we
both risk we both tried to get the test
and as many of you may know at this
point you have to be um in a high risk
group which is all older people and um
and people with compromised immune
systems or uh you have to have it has to
be further along in your system and and
severe enough in your system because i
it sounds like this illness manifests
itself in so many different ways uh for
for people and and maybe the most
insidious part is that many people like
this is what i think happened to me are
asymptomatic or barely symptomatic and
um it's like we have corona light yeah
it's true we have
had you been thinking about that joke
that's funny no um it's funny funny i
mean i have seen it online oh really but
i can't recall for sure it's tough it's
weird because there's so much um this is
bringing so much pain to so many people
and um
so it's strange to know
how to joke i mean i i also have really
been enjoying a lot of
online humor uh surrounding this thing
um if you don't already probably do but
follow kristen bell she's she's really
great at curating very useful
information and very funny memes and
stuff but um
yeah it's weird i i've been hearing some
people say like oh you shouldn't be
joking now i've also heard about this
podcast and others that it's it's a
welcome
relief from from all of the corona news
uh not this one
this one that's what i thought you meant
no i the the last few that we've done oh
yeah yeah the show though the show yeah
but not this show not this arrogant to
say
some people have said it i'm not saying
it is
a relief uh but people i'm quoting very
generous
people who are who enjoy the podcast
okay but yeah it's generally it it'd be
uh no i'm not saying be arrogant if i
said i'm not saying it is a arrogant i'm
not asking if it was we're like a safe
humorous harbor in this storm in this
uh pandemic storm um we are going today
to just so you know we're going to do
this obviously very different uh than
our usual shows first of all uh we're
quarantined um second of all we heard of
a guest because we're quarantined third
of all we have no idea what we're doing
uh no we're going we're actually gonna
check in if you listen to the show
you'll you may have heard our
grandmother on the show so we're gonna
check in with her and that's that's been
the biggest concern of ours um
is our own parents because they're older
uh our dad's in his 80s now mom's in her
don't want to say uh i don't want to out
her but she's older uh because she's a
woman you're not allowed to say older no
you just outed his age she was always
weird because she was an actress too she
was always weird about me
saying her she's in her 70s but she
looks great and she's got and she's full
of life for someone in her 70s if i look
like her if um at her age i'd be proud i
hope you look like her now not exactly
like her
no i would be proud to to be
that that old that age yeah i'd say
like grandma i think at this point is
proud of her age but she used to be a
little embarrassed you know i don't see
myself ever being weird about my age
and wanting people to think i'm younger
i just i don't care if people if i'm
older i'm right i already feel older i
am older i know i'm i don't because i
think part of it is that for so long i
was
or i was we both were late bloomers and
i think throughout a lot of my childhood
i always wanted
to look old because i felt older because
i felt insecure about being so little
and young looking for my class yeah
that's right you both have to have been
underdeveloped when you were younger
before you went through puberty uh but i
always wanted to
people to think i was older so i don't
know if i ever completely me lost that i
remember being on the train uh we would
when we sometimes we would go with our
mother to commute she was an actress and
she would go into the city for auditions
into new york city and um
and we would get uh child prices do you
remember this
oh i used to get child prices which i
think i may be wrong on the edge but it
was like
nope it's a corona cough sorry uh
it is weird that you have this i'm
pretty sure you i'm pretty sure i have
it this really horrific thing that
everybody's talking about um
that you just have a mild version of it
that that version of it um but again
we're uh no fever
um
yeah in five days i'll have completed my
requisite 14-day quarantine oh it's
exciting what are you well just to
finish my thought really sorry my mother
used to lie about uh our age to get uh
kid prices on this she did yeah and i
how old did you have to be together
that's what i was trying to remember
like seven i think seven or eight seven
i think and um i remember being like 12
uh and getting seven-year-old prices oh
that's really tiny you were a tinier for
your age than i was even i was uh going
into high school i was because i had to
get weighed and measured for have i said
this before i was yeah i mean to me four
foot nine i was four foot nine i weighed
88 pounds wow anyway uh you're still
very small for an adult
yeah thanks you are i'm not very small
uh you are you're very light for an
adult yeah man
that that much yeah i thought you were
140. i used to be here i'm gained a
little bit
right you gained some toffee weight
yeah from um angstroms i gained some
angstrom's weight uh free free ad free
ad yeah by the way we're not doing ads
today that's another uh thing but you
may like or
or or you may miss the answer also our
shows will go back to um oh yeah every
tuesday we're still gonna have our
regular shows yes we're gonna do that
and once we we have a bunch of guests uh
in the in the bank but once we run out
of those because i think this might be
going on for
uh you know you hear different things
but um
i think we're we're good on guests right
now up in up until the end of april
we're gonna check in with grandma um see
how she's doing and uh yeah if you're
like us you're worried for your older
relatives and you are if you're also
like us your older relatives have been
very stubborn about going out and
running ridiculously unnecessary errands
um our dad was going to go out yesterday
and my mother stopped him and was like
why why he's like i gotta go to trader
joe's she said why he's like well i need
uh the dogs they're our dogs like these
little baby carrots he's like you know
for the little carrots she's like i have
carrots he's like yeah but they like the
the little ones
she's like i'll cut them up uh
so yeah stay home everyone okay here we
go
oh failed huh
ver yous are busy weird
huh
what's she up to
not a busy lady
these are busy i'm going to try herself
now why am i trying on her cell if her
other she's on the phone yeah yeah all
right
um wow this is not turning out too well
um okay we're also going to check in we
call our own mother
yeah should we yeah all right just for a
few minutes okay let's see how that goes
it should be fun
uh okay
yeah she's also
fun to talk to she's the younger version
of graham
much younger
this is sad no one's answering us
[Laughter]
and we know that they're there that's
the thing with this quarantine like when
you call a friend now and they don't
answer it's like uh i know
i know where you are
um
well we have some letters from people
also we're going to read uh many people
who are not lucky enough to be hi this
is wendy
no one's answering don't tell jerry
really oh yeah cherry cheers for a few
minutes okay we'll do a quick check in
with jerry
uh
jerry a former guest on
here's jerry o'connell
i hope he puts his kids on
have you ever met the kids
charlie and dolly they're twins but they
look nothing alike one looks like uh
rebecca i'm like rebecca
one looks like [ __ ] sorry the mailbox is
full and there is not enough space to
leave a message why doesn't he send a
message to oh he just told us to go all
right we'll see if he calls back um but
for the time being let's read a letter
uh this is a letter from
i don't know who yet
justin and christian hello
excuse me sorry
like the rest of the world we are all
working to find a new normal and routine
in these unique times i was hoping to
move to new york city this month but
life has put a slight delay in my plans
and i've been with my parents in
pennsylvania for a minute they are
wonderfully prepared as [ __ ] and we are
getting creative to make the most of
this time i'm a dancer and all of my
jobs projects upcoming travel and
teaching have been cancelled or
postponed for months
so i'm treating this a bit like quote an
artist retreat to fill up my cup with
things that inspire me i we have nothing
but the gift of time to create for the
joy of creating take all of the free
classes online
read listen to music and podcasts watch
random online tutorials make lists of
new goals and actionable steps to reach
them and all the things we can't do when
we are so quote busy with work letting
all the things i'm curious about guide
my path that's cool
so all that being said here's a list of
the random [ __ ] my family and i are
doing to stay sane while staying at home
my parents and i are rocking our daily 9
30 a.m workouts together and having a
blast that's cool it's fun we have such
different parents
i know well that's something mom would
do yeah for sure um which is either
adorable or sad i think it's adorable
but oh so fun why sad
our dogs are staring at us like we are
crazy people
that's funny we're hitting up at least
one puppy walk every day to get out of
the house and get some vitamin d oh yeah
i've been taking vitamin d our pups have
never been happier and more tired we
have been connecting for family game
nights with my sisters and their
families using the app zoom
not a sponsor but it's been helpful to
us too we're editing a movie and we've
been using it ourselves so we can
interact in real time laugh and pretend
we are all together my nieces and
nephews are loving it i've made healthy
boundaries with the news because [ __ ] is
scary david muir
your favorite in mine has made the cut
yeah good he's great uh he
he's my go-to guy with the world news at
6 30 p.m and the only news i'll watch
because 30 minutes of the highlights is
enough
that's a very good point i started
meditating it's no tm
but
oh yeah
yeah yeah i know i know that's something
i wasn't able to do i was going to do
that zack quinto a former guest hooked
me up with you can't do it online uh oh
maybe maybe
uh but oprah is back the letter but
oprah and deepak
have a 21 day meditation about hope that
came out right on time i like that she
calls deepak by his just his first name
we also started our garden a bit early i
gotta do that i planted a basil plant
named tony hey do you get that
uh you don't get it
no tony basil i don't know what that
means hey mickey you're so fine you're
so funny you blow my mind hey song
his name is tony basil
yeah i think it's a woman well i've
never heard that
well now jokes on me it might be thanks
for shaming me for not knowing
that's the video don't get that you
might be a little young for that uh
that's funny i planted a basil plant i
planted a basil plant named tony and the
papa bear planted his tomatoes cucumber
zuki she sounds like a children a book
and a children a character in a
children's book
and the papa bear planet is tomatoes
cucumbers zucchini string beans and a
few more i think
i don't know where she lives it's a
little early here where we are in
connecticut um although it's really
beautiful it's beautiful 64 degrees yeah
god i can't wait to get into the garden
everything says to watch comedies or
lighthearted shows to keep the mood
light and i came across dodgeball and
laughed harder than ever ah i forgot how
many good one-liners are in that film it
was just what i needed yeah that script
was so [ __ ] good it was called
underdogs originally when i first read
it i know
i'm sorry sorry
ross and marshall thurber shout out to
the writer director um been taking all
the online dance classes and on-demand
yoga or bar how do you pronounce this is
it bar classes bahrain bar it's bar yeah
oh boy
uh
i miss going to bar raise
been teaching some ballet
ballet and hip hop with zoom to my
sister's kiddos and to my sister's
friend's daughters that's cool been
doodling painting coloring and doing
anything crafty to keep my brain and
body engaged
she is you know what's so much more
active in quarantine than most people
are in the real world
more so than i am yeah and
non-quarantined
my sisters and i have started asking
each other random questions every day to
introduce funny stories and new topics
what a great idea i asked my sisters to
write their bucket lists and their kids
are doing a version of it too that's
i would love to read a kid's bucket list
wouldn't you
that's cool uh back to the letter five
things to do before they are a hundred
it's going to be adorable which i bet it
is things you do so many more than that
i know but for a kid to come over you
know we will all share tonight or
tomorrow after james lipton passed
we asked each other the same 10
questions he used to ask his guests in
his in his honor i butchered that line
i'm sorry so they asked the same
questions i met him once do you ever
meet him i did a couple times uh he was
very nice to me last time i saw him it
was for uh we were both on andy cohen's
show watch what happens live and he
was really sweet to it he obliged andy
cohen a fellow kovid yeah
yeah that's right you know sorry we were
going all these like digressions but um
an actor that i really loved worked with
years ago a wonderful actor named mark
blum
passed away yesterday from covid uh and
and of course terence mcnally a couple
days before that so it's it's
starting to claim some really
just just great people so it's been
sad i understand um her name is jess's i
understand her uh
hesitation to watch too much in the news
because it can be overwhelming uh this
kind of tragedy but um
yeah lipton was really cool he was
really nice to me he was sweet he uh he
let me do um a little bit film a little
bit for instagram i should i should put
that on
anyway
um back to the letter uh i'd love to
hear what you and christian answer to
james lipton's questions we should do
that in his honor has to be the first
thing that pops into your mind no
dwelling over the question i agree
lightning round style questions included
at the end
good what are you guys doing to stay
sane during all this seems like you guys
are having a ball together uh yeah you
just laughed no we are it's just funny
to imagine us like having a ball having
a ball together
i know
i know but i could have danced
i could
uh savoring the time to slow down look
out the window and appreciate the simple
[ __ ]
excuse me and watching gary the
groundhog run
who's carrying the groundhog
run or waddle through oh that's their
groundhog specific to their yard
run or waddle through our backyard each
day it is an impactful time and we'll
have stories for the ages to share you
know i had a groundhog in my garden last
year and it decimated the whole garden
yeah
i didn't name him because i didn't find
him to be all that cute
uh the guy the hardware store one you
named him pol pot
yeah although paul pott is a cute name
yeah it is i know he was a really awful
person dictator um
anyway back to the letter thank you for
keeping us smiling with all you guys do
stay safe stay stay healthy stay
connected to those you love and to
strangers too i guess jess uh that is
really nice and and um thanks just god
and what an impressive
what an impressive quarantine time for
jess uh she said i'd love to hear your
responses to these questions shoot a
reply or text or answer on the podcast
for fun
she included her number but i think we
we've done a lot of and we're going to
try to get jerry so we've done a lot of
check-ins but um and i feel like we
should include the questions in the back
she did so here we go
so the first one you answer for a second
one i'll answer first and then alternate
well
sorry every time you cough i get a
little nervous you have it i i know i
know jay you don't both have to have a
mild form of growth james lipton's
questions from inside the actor studio
number one
what is your favorite word
poo
oh a turd i like a lot
um
but yeah okay but it's curse word right
is this supposed to be curse words you
said favorite word all right what is
your least favorite word
squish
uh
death
uh yeah
yeah
lie i don't like that
um what turns you on
tube tops
honesty
what turns you off
hypocrisy
people who are mean bullies
uh what sound or noise do you love
you know what i love uh spring peepers
ah i swear to god
did you know i was gonna say that how
would i know that
oh that's funny i thought you knew that
because i've talked about it you don't
both have to love the sound of spring
beepers uh i do too spring peepers all
right we can have the same answer i know
i know cicadas are nice too
springtime sounds the nighttime sounds
of of spring the crickets and
uh what sound or noise do you hate
horns uh traffic sound in new york like
cab horns you know what i kind of hate
is when um i'm in a quiet place like at
a play or something and my stomach is
like boom
oh you don't like that sound no it's
embarrassing but the sound itself you
hate and no i just don't hate the sound
itself i just hate that
yeah i guess i do in that moment because
of what it it does to me socially i also
hate this sound
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is your favorite curse word
it's hard to be you know i hate to say
it but the [ __ ]
i hate to say this it's a terrible word
but but if calling a guy a [ __ ] is
really effective yeah you know um
i i can't say it's my favorite because
it's such an ugly word i know i know but
um i like [ __ ]
and [ __ ] is great [ __ ] you're such an
[ __ ] calling a guy at [ __ ] is really
good twat's good yeah
you both have to like the words
um
okay what uh what profession other than
your own would you like to attempt
uh i always thought i'd be a good
lawyer like a good um yeah like a public
defender you would be a good lawyer yeah
you would you're very rational you're
very good at like arguing but not in an
argumentative way from a very
rational standpoint reasonable logic
thank you
um
i would like to attempt to be a
i'd like to like teach kids i'd like to
do something with kids like uh
i don't know like nurses nanny
yeah yeah but like several kids would be
fun to like be like a kindergarten
kindergarten yeah that'd be fun right um
[Music]
what is uh what profession other oh i
did that what profession would you not
like to do oh that's that's
so many yeah
yeah oh i wouldn't mind being the
zookeeper i know well we're very
different in that respect
yeah anything with money anything with
finance like um
like a hedge fund manager oh god
yeah i mean no disrespect to the hedge
fund managers listening but that'd be
tough for me okay um
if heaven exists what would you like to
hear god say when you arrive at the
pearly gates
um
here's a big bowl of mint chocolate chip
ice cream
hey what took you so long
i fee i feel like if he has ice cream
for me then
everything else is probably gonna be
okay yeah but what if it's only ice
cream then you get sick of ice cream
well don't ruin my
sorry
careful you're about to knock that thing
off wow sorry
all right thanks um okay oh mom's
calling all right okay
is everything okay uh yeah oh yeah we
were just calling because uh we wondered
if you wanted to say anything on on the
podcast
oh uh yeah i would but i'm just about to
start my walk i'm at the university oh
okay oh good all right so you're taking
uh no that's okay we'll get you next
time yeah we'll get you next time but
but uh just so you're staying active
you're going outside and keeping up with
the walks
i'm keeping up with the walks and i just
hope i don't meet anybody
oh well just don't just say hi and be
nice but but from a nice
from
safe
distance
okay all right have a good walk
okay honey okay bye
okay
all right okay
are there more questions uh no that's it
the heaven question that was a really
great letter thanks jess
um
uh i i just want to recommend a few
things to you yes please
um
bob dylan dropped a song as bob dylan
would say that that's in his words uh
the draft is selling today um it's
really beautiful it's a kind of
rumination on the
kennedy assassination and um it's really
interesting that he
dylan he's a singer-songwriter oh is
that jacob dylan's father yes oh yes as
a matter of fact um yeah did you not
know he was a singer i did i forgot yeah
stupid
um it's been it was really beautiful to
listen to that today and you know some
you think 17-minute song um in a in a
non-quarantined time uh that that might
seem daunting but uh one of the nice
things and jess touches on this in her
letter is that we some of us who those
of us who are lucky enough to be able to
quarantine um have time to do things
like that and it's a real gift to be
able to sit and listen to music i've
been
doing that i've been i've been watching
i've been finding watching old familiar
shows it's really nice it's like
i've said it too many times but you get
it's the sense that you're like hanging
out with a friend um you know it's
really good too um
this show and practical jokers oh god is
it good
it is so if you need a laugh and i think
we all do right now
i cannot recommend this enough it is so
funny it's on
uh hulu it's on true tv it is
these four friends lifelong friends sal
volcano and um murr and
they're all so funny and they all play
jokes on each other it's really great um
yeah that's been making us laugh uh we
love the the documentary monterey um
some incredible footage of janice joplin
and
jimi hendrix at the monterey uh music
festival what else oh irishman we
finally saw the irishman
oh man i don't get it we christian and i
were wondering if it was if it'd be more
entertaining to
re-watch the irishman or just watch an
irishman alone at a bar
yeah uh what do you think progressively
getting drunker by himself yeah i should
have
that i think would be far more
entertaining
far more i mean look far more right
um
i hate to disparage martin scorsese he's
a genius of course
but of course that's what made this so
surprising and incredible reviews i know
i
i was not
i mean the the biggest problem i had
with it was the ridiculous um uh
oh you know the majority of
making them look younger and i mean de
niro it's not his fault he's an old man
now but he they they do this cgi makeup
to make him look like he's a middle-aged
man but he moves like an old man they
they can't fix that but you know so it's
so strange it's strange there's there's
scenes of him he plays this this is
tough this heavy
and he uh there's scenes of him
beating people up and it's
ridiculous it's a little bit like if
you've seen bowfinger at the end of
bowfinger uh eddie murphy
his character is in some big action
movie and he can he's barely punching
these stunts that's what it's like yeah
and it's it's so obvious and again yeah
not deniro's fault as great of an actor
as he is
you can't act like your body is younger
than it is
um and even the way they make him up uh
cgi it's
he's even too old
i think for that character that
character should have been like
maybe early 30s but but late 20s really
like kind of like ray leota's character
and goodfellas it shows him starting out
how he how he came to to be in a
position of prominence in in the mob and
uh
it's weird it's just very strange so
everyone go watch uh good fellas yeah go
watch goodfellas oh god or raging bull
yeah or or mean streets or uh yeah taxi
driver all all the earlier ones um
and uh and catch up on old old shows you
might find comfort in it the way we have
uh all right
i'm gonna go rest yeah i'm gonna rest my
corona riddled body you need to um but
please keep writing in because uh we
really have enjoyed hearing from you
um and we really hope you're staying
safe and healthy out there
uh
especially if you are one of the people
who are who are working now and and we
can't tell you how grateful we are
um that you're continuing to work so we
all all of us staying at home
um get the things that we need to keep
life going and not quite as weird if you
have any extra money if you're fortunate
if you are privileged and can donate to
um feed america or uh no kid hungry is a
really great organization because a lot
of those kids rely on school to provide
them with meals and a lot of those
families as it is are are having a
difficult time providing meals uh so no
kid hungry sort of fills in that gap
excuse me uh so if you can
check out no kid hungry and um or or
your local food banks because
we're going to need it now in the coming
months more than ever and again thank
you all so much thank you to everyone
at the hospitals on the front lines of
the medical field who are keeping us
safe
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you've been listening to a special
quarantine episode of life short which
was hosted by
justin long me it's produced by me
christian long and megan monaco our
senior producer is michelle mish lands
our audio engineers sergio enriquez
executive producers are
marshall louis and ernan lopez for
wondering but definitely stay tuned for
another normal non-quarantine edition of
life is short on tuesday
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
you